[Musique]
choisir un membre de son cabinet deux
membres de son cabinet sur toi c'est
vraiment une façon de dire moi j'ai
confiance quand bagarre de rapprocher ce
que l'on observe en fait c'est un
véritable enfermement du pouvoir sur lui
même mon coloc que chez ce ministre dans
ses collaborateurs c'est qu'il n'y a
plus une grande capacité d'ouverture
parce qu'il n'a pas eu la lucidité
l'honnêteté de mener à un moment donné
la politique qu'il faut mener en france
nous en sommes maintenant à la
restitution des travaux du grand débat
qui a eu lieu
c'est une étape très importante la
france est dans une crise très
importante donc on n'est pas là pour
faire un casting entre amis pour essayer
de porter la parole du président
uniquement du président si le prison
dorée public était content dauguet c'est
parce qu'il a échoué et jouets
réconcilier les français échouent et en
matière de prélèvements obligatoires ou
des tno l'europe hors des pays de l'
ocde échoué en termes de dépenses
publiques nous avons une dépense
publique supérieure à celle de françois
hollande échoué en matière de déficits
publics où nous avons eu pire déficit
public de la zone euro yves que l'italie
nous nous sommes plaints interrogation
parce que le débat au bout d'un moment
ça suffit tout le monde en a marre
maintenant de grands débats on est
épuisé c'est long très long trop long et
il est temps maintenant d'en sortir est
effectivement de prendre des décisions
[Musique]
une droite qui s'assume une droite qui
n'a pas de compromission avec le
maquereau nice une droite qui rejettent
les extrêmes et une droite qui va
représenter la seule alternance crédible
et responsable parce que nous nous
refusons le duo mortifère entre le pen
et maquereau thon mais construisons
l'europe qu'il nous faut c'est à dire
une europe qui nous protège pas l'europe
de marine le pen puisque elle elle veut
avec son ex futur premier ministre
monsieur dupont-aignan déconstruire
l'union européenne et d'un autre côté
monsieur macro lui veut élargir l'union
européenne moi je crois que nous ne
pouvons pas inventer notre avenir sans
une alliance forte en europe parce que
notre avenir ça n'est pas celui d'une
fragmentation de nos nations qui
resterait isolé dans la mondialisation